la scène et chaotique les images
désolantes et l'ampleur des dégâts après
les déraillements survenus dans la nuit
montre toute la force de l'impact entre
les trois trains entrés en collision
près de balaçores dans l'est de l'Inde
toute la nuit les équipes de sauvetage
se sont affairés à sortir les survivants
des carcasses de train une opération qui
s'est poursuivie en journée avec l'aide
de chien pour fouiller les décombres les
cordes de dizaines de victimes ont été
retrouvés vu l'ampleur de la tragédie le
Premier ministre indien narraine
ramondie s'est rendu sur les lieux de
l'accident en plus des rencontres de
coordination le Premier ministre a aussi
rendu visite à des survivants dans un
hôpital local d'où il a fait une annonce
Jovi dont
responsable ne sera épargné et la
punition la plus sévère sera donnée
a-t-il dit des indemnités financières
seront aussi remises aux familles des
victimes et aux blessés qui ont survécu
pendant ce temps l'Inde pleure les
victimes de l'accident le pays n'en est
malheureusement pas à sa première
catastrophe ferroviaire même si la
sécurité s'était considérablement
améliorée ces dernières années depuis le
début du siècle très accident
ferroviaire ont chacun fait plus de 50
morts trois ont été causés par des
attentats comme dans le train de
l'amitié entre l'Inde et le Pakistan en
2007 l'accident le plus meurtrier
remonte cependant à juin 1981 il avait
fait près de 800 morts ici Xavier savoir
fournir Radio-Canada Montréal